morning thanks for having me and thanks
for coming out I know the the u.s.
soccer match going up against that I'm
pretty impressed with the turnout I kind
of I said came to thinking there was
gonna be four people here today we're
gonna be in a kumbaya table so I'm
excited by show of hands how many of you
saw my speech two years ago
raise your hands great thank you and by
show of hands how many of you have no
idea who I am
please raise your hands yeah that
[ __ ] hurts that's a tough way to
start a morning okay so I apologize for
the 20-30 percent that have heard some
of this but since so many of you don't
I'm gonna set up a little bit of context
then I'm gonna speak a little bit about
what I would call the current state of
selling stuff in America I mean we can
call it social media but I want to make
sure that everybody in this room
understands the only reason I care about
social media is because it sells stuff
and whether you're b2b or b2c in this
room trying to get to the consumer about
your project what you're building or a
vendor or trying to get to the
developers in this room and become part
of that business model
I am completely convinced understanding
the context of this room and being here
a couple years ago I'm completely
convinced with my entire heart and soul
that even the most progressive in this
room are grossly under estimating what's
actually going on in our society right
now when you incorporate the digital
changes we're living through and that's
where I want to focus on the truth is as
I stand here you know I'm about to give
a keynote speech I feel pretty good
about it it's gonna go well you're gonna
get excited because I get excited all
that good stuff but then next Thursday
happens and all the rallying we're gonna
do this morning kind of goes on the
wayside when actual business gets in the
way and so just to set the tone
my biggest agenda here this morning is
to convince one person of the reality of
the marketplace and have that one person
actually execute let me explain
I was born in uh in Belarus and a former
Soviet Union I came to the United States
when I was three years old my family
emigrated to Queens New York eight
family members in a studio apartment
half the size of this stage very ghetto
upbringing my dad really it's kind of
fun to say that in this room my dad was
in the construction business in the
Soviet Union when we came to the US it
was the late 70s my dad thought he was
gonna get a construction job I see a lot
of faces in this room sure plenty of you
remember the late 70s the the market
wasn't so great so my dad had to get a
bunch of side jobs one of them was to be
a stock boy in a liquor store in Clark
New Jersey
my dad commuted from Queens to Clark for
an hour each day getting paid 2 bucks an
hour it was kind of that story right I
kind of lived the American Dream story
first-generation immigrant I probably
associate with more of the grandparents
of the people in this room than the
people in this room that's kind of my
life when we moved to Edison New Jersey
because my dad became the manager of
this liquor store in Clark I started my
first entrepreneurial venture I had a
six lemonade stand franchise now I'm now
how many of you remember the big wheels
those little bikes remember I used to
ride my big wheels at the end of every
summer day collecting my cash from my
friends like I was little Tony Soprano
or something so that was good made a
couple hundred bucks which was a ton of
money for our immigrant family
especially at age 6 and 7 when I was 12
I started my first real actual business
in 1987 if some of you recall baseball
cards were the phenomenon of America and
so I would do baseball card shows I
would rent a table for 200 bucks
and sell baseball cards in the malls of
New York and New Jersey when you know
and I was making two to three thousand
dollars a weekend selling baseball cards
of this age which you know if you're 14
and you have a $30,000 in cash under
your bed and you're not selling
we'd you're doing a good job so uh so
that was big you know I do think a
thanks Brian I do think that I will buy
the New York Jets one day but I do know
that I will never be more rich than when
I was 14 and had 30,000 in cash because
Nintendo was like 200 bucks I don't know
what to do with the money right when I
was 15 my dad ruined my life
being the first born immigrant son
my dad had now executed on his American
Dream from 1978 when we came to the US
until 1985 and that seven-year window we
spent $0 on anything we saved every
dollar and that allowed my dad to buy a
small liquor store in Springfield New
Jersey he started building it up I
became a teenager and as you can imagine
he dragged me into the family business
like every immigrant family does and he
paid me two bucks an hour to work in the
basement bagging ice for 15 hours a day
so I went from making four to five
thousand dollars three thousand dollars
a weekend to making $30 a weekend
bagging ice in the basement of my dad's
store I did that every weekend and every
summer vacation for two straight years I
call those the dark ages when I was 17
16 I was finally allowed to come
upstairs who saw the movie The Goonies
Goonies
I was literally sloth remember sloth
who's like chained to the basement that
was me for two years of my dad's store I
was finally allowed to come upstairs and
something very interesting happened I
hated the liquor business I wanted to
get involved in my family business
because it's just kind of what you do
when you're like that way but I didn't
want to sell liquor and beer and it just
wasn't that interesting to me but we
were lucky we were in Springfield New
Jersey which is actually around Short
Hills summit Livingston New Jersey
affluent areas if you know that area and
so in the early 90s as wine started to
become something in America that we
cared about
we felt the impact of that because we
just have a fluent customers around and
even though my dad's store was called
shoppers discount liquors you know you
kind of now know why I rebranded it
people came in and asking for wine and
I'm one fateful day everybody came in
and asked for Camus special select
Cabernet Sauvignon 1990 which was just
named the wine of the Year by the Wine
Spectator after a series of questions
with 30 different customers asking for
that bottle I realized something very
special which was people collected wine
and once I made that connection of
Michael Jordan Wayne Gretzky Ken Griffey
jr. which is what I was doing with my
baseball cards silver oak Camus Chateau
Lafite same crap and so I took all my
passion from learning about stats of
sports to no 16 year old in the world
should know as much as I did about Pinot
Noir and Sancerre and everything and for
the first time in my life I went from
I'm gonna open up nine that was in
baseball card stores one day sell the
franchise and buy the Jets two I'm gonna
open up nine thousand liquor stores and
wine shops sell the franchise and buy
the Jets right that became the plan at
that moment my freshman year of college
now I was a DNF student and as a
freshman in college I probably spent 20
minutes on a computer in my entire life
I just want every single person to pay
attention to what I'm about to say I'm
about to spend the next half an hour
talking about technical stuff computers
and social media and the cloud the
Internet all this stuff and I've been
doing this a long time and a lot of
people in this room who are running
businesses successfully long before all
this stuff always like to say things
like Gary I get it but I didn't grow up
with this stuff right I just want
everybody to know I did not grow up with
this stuff I was not techie I did not
own a computer I was 19 years old when
this faithful day happened where I was
in my dorm room playing Madden 94
dominating by the way my friend ran in
said you have to come and see this I
went to his dorm room there's ten dudes
standing in front of a computer I at
least knew what a computer was but like
just to put into context I had a word
processor that I was supposed to use to
write papers I didn't but I had
and they're standing in front of it and
it was the first time I heard cuckoo Shh
remember NAT sound AOL four bucks a
minute
dial-up internet real ripoff anyway and
it and and I said this amazing statement
I said is this the information
superhighway that's what we used to call
it youngsters it was pretty sad anyway
and my friend Joe looked me dead in the
face and he said the words that changed
my life forever which was he signed on
it was a oh L 1994 signed on looked me
dead in the face and he said we can get
chicks on this thing so we did age sex
location some of you remember ASL I
waited I this is how to put it into
context I waited for hours for my chance
to get on the internet I watched for
four hours ten other people sit down and
go on the internet because it was that
mind-blowing this is only twenty years
ago to put into context right I jumped
on and within 15 minutes I realized
poking around clicking hitting a couple
buttons I realized holy crap
I can sell stuff on this thing and it
was the first time I ever thought about
not spending the money or time or
infrastructure to launch nine thousand
this or nine thousand that I said I can
launch something on this sell it and buy
the New York Jets this is where it
starts becoming important to you guys in
1998 I went into my family liquor store
business full time in 1996 while still
being a sophomore in school I launched
the second ever ecommerce wine business
in the u.s. called winelibrary.com I
rebranded my family business to Wine
Library and from 1998 to 2005 in a
seven-year window I grew my family
business from a three to a sixty five
million dollar business now here's
what's important where it crosses over
to us in the building industry I did a
lot of things that at seven years that
map to a lot of things that are being
done by the practitioners here which was
no marketing I did the Yellow Pages I
did newspaper ads I did
local radio I did buy in the b2b
magazine
I did buy billboards and local cable and
I did so much goddamn direct mail that I
still look at trees sometimes and think
they're pissed at me I mean I I did all
those things but there's something else
I did that I want to harp on in this
room today that is what matters I have
now had a 20-year professional career I
built my family business to a large
business I started a social media agency
four years ago with my brother AJ I've
grown that from 20 to 400 employees into
a 50 million dollar revenue business in
36 months I invested in things like
Twitter and Facebook and Tumblr and uber
and Birchbox and have watched these
businesses go from seed round funding to
billion-dollar companies in five years I
also have General Electric and Mountain
Dew and dove and GE and all these
enormous fortune 100 companies as
clients for the last four years I've
seen small businesses entrepreneurship
fortune 500 I've played the gamut
there's one thing that I want every
person in this room you need to think
about if you write down anything from
this talk if that's how you roll or if
you remember anything from this talk let
me explain to you the one thing that
connects all those businesses that I've
seen win and the one thing that connects
all the businesses that I've seen lose
aka when I begged with all my heart for
Blockbuster to pay attention to this
thing called Netflix and they didn't
give a [ __ ] and now they give a [ __ ]
unfortunately they're dead so they don't
give anything so the one common thread
the one thing that finds every person in
this room whether you're a vendor b2b
contractor developer the one thing that
is a common theme and is going to be the
variable the single variable to why
people in this room 10 years from now
are successful versus the ones that are
not going to be as successful there's
only one variable the one thing that I'm
good at
the one reason that I've been honored to
be able to stand in front of you again
here today twice in three years the one
reason I've been able to build
businesses so quickly pick startups that
have made me a lot of money by going
public like Facebook and Twitter and
uber next is I actually suck at 99% of
things when it comes to business I'm
super a DD not that organized I make a
lot of mistakes
I'm chaotic but there's one thing that
got me here and it's the one thing I
want everybody to focus on in this room
the one theme for success is are you
marketing in the year that we actually
live in and I just want to sit here for
13 seconds quiet for a dramatic pause
because I want everybody to really think
about what I just said if you are
sitting here and you think about how you
spend your time and money to make more
money and it doesn't map to the behavior
of the people that you're trying to sell
to in 2014 you are vulnerable
why did blockbuster go out of business
blockbuster passed on by Netflix for 25
million dollars the past they sat in a
boardroom and they said next agenda
Netflix do we want to buy it for twenty
five million dollars by the way this is
like seven years ago it's not so long
ago and they pass do you know why my
favorite thing in business and some of
the bigger organizations here people
gonna start laughing their data showed
that their customers didn't care their
data showed that their customers liked
going to the store and touching the DVDs
their data showed that their customers
liked going to the stores because they
might serendipitously run into one of
their neighbors that's what their data
showed I don't know about you guys but
here's the experience I like pressing
one button while I'm naked in bed and
watching the [ __ ] that I want to watch
how many people here now watch
television outside of live sports and
award shows
now watch television on your time
meaning you're not tuning in when it
airs you're watching on DVR TiVo
on-demand Netflix on the go
HBO raise your hands don't [ __ ] me
raise your hands if you watch raise it
high because I want everybody in the
front area to look back real quick raise
your hand if you watch television on
your time okay thank you I'm gonna guess
that that's about 95 percent of this
room now I think we can all agree with
all due respect to this room that this
is not a high school-aged crowd right
and 95% of the hands went up in this
room because you now watch television on
your time because technology has caught
up to an opportunity where you can do
the things you want to do on your time
not when it actually happens right and
so 95% of this room watches TV now on
your time just curious by show of hands
how many people in this room in this
year the first six months of this year
when watching those TV shows have
fast-forwarded every single commercial
reason interesting another 90 percent
meanwhile 10 billion dollars and money
is spent to make commercials and
distribute them to tell you a story
about the products my clients are
spending billions of dollars trying to
tell you how good their soda or bottled
water or services several different
people in here within your
organization's are running local
television to tell you how good this
thing is and you should buy it
we're storytelling like it's 2006 or
2003 or 1994 even for the people that
didn't raise their hand in here the 20
of them if a commercial is lucky enough
to get by right like maybe you dropped
your remote off your bed right even if
the commercials lucky enough to sneak by
and tell you how great a product is
every person here when it goes to
commercial and they're not changing
channel is taking their attention and
they're giving it to their phone to
check their email or to tweet out what
they just saw because my friends the
other thing that binds everybody in this
room the number one thing even more
importantly than what I said earlier
which is market in the year that we live
in because the truth is some of you will
be lucky enough to not market in the
year that we live in and hold on for
long enough to where you don't care
anymore
right and that's about how many people
here by show hands are retiring in the
next six years and I don't mean I don't
mean you're gonna crush it I mean you're
you're old and tired and you're finished
six years raise your hand raise your
hands if you're retiring in six years
raise your hands real quick retiring at
six years all right so for the nine of
you for the nine of you in this room I
respect you taking where I'm going with
this with a little bit of a grain of
salt you're probably gonna be able to
hold off just enough to where it's not
gonna move fast enough to really disrupt
your current landscape of business and
you'll be on your way
fishing camping enjoy it thanks for all
the hard work but for the rest of you
the speed in which innovation is
happening is extraordinary and that's
what we need to focus on how many people
here spend money trying to reach how
many people here consider themselves in
b2b raise your hand
b2b you're trying to reach somebody
great and how many people consider
themselves b2c raise your hands great so
more b2c which is where where this
really matters but I would argue that
the 30 percent of this room that's in
b2b doesn't actually think this is very
important to them that they feel like
well my customers or who I'm trying to
reach are not on these platforms right
that they're not so the decision-maker
is not spending his or her time on
Facebook or Twitter or things of that
nature
let me paint you a picture of how we do
b2b business my current agency is b2b I
can tell you there's a really remarkable
tactic I'm gonna I've been trying to
make my keynotes less philosophical and
more tactical so people leave and
actually get impacted by them not just
emotionally but it changes their bottom
line so for the b2b people in this room
I want you to really pay attention to
what I'm about to say I
a four million dollar account for my
company very recently spending about 17
minutes using social media let me
explain I have been in b2c with a 70
million dollar wine business I'm now in
b2b I can tell you right now
and take it for how it is it is way
easier to be in the b2b business it is a
business where you actually know the
name of your customer you actually know
exactly who you're trying to reach I
remember all my friends that wouldn't be
to be when I was doing the whites and I
go b2b use hard is it be me is awesome
especially in the world we live in now I
know the name of the CMOS that I have to
reach for them to hire my company or the
brand manager things that nature so
recently I wanted to target this one
company so I put the person's name into
Google right and then I added the word
Twitter after it and Facebook and sure
enough and I do this for about six
people I was targeting to them of the
six did have Twitter accounts even
though they're in their 60s and they
shouldn't and all that the world is
aging down very quickly I'll get into
that in a minute and then I started
following the two people that I was
targeting on Twitter and I didn't tweet
them and say hey Johnny you should check
out vaynermedia we're a great company
we'd love to work with you know that's
throwing a right hook without throwing
any jabs right
that's not romancing that's not playing
the long game so I just watched what
this gentleman was talking about and
what this gentleman was talking about
was kolten Wong who here knows who
kolten Wong is raise your hand
very nice either Cardinal fans and/or
fantasy baseball players he's a young
second baseman for the st. Louis
Cardinals and for some ungodly reason
this 60 year old CMO that I wanted his
money was really into him and talking
about him and excited for the upcoming
baseball season ironically two weeks
later was my fantasy baseball draft and
we do auction not the [ __ ] draft
stuff we throw out the name and we bid
hardcore so I'm sitting and waiting and
drafting along my team and then sure
enough
my cousin Bobby goes kolten Wong $1 and
kolten Wong was barely on my radar I
felt pretty good about my middle infield
but that something reminded me while he
was being bid on of this CMO who loved
kolten Wong and I decided to bid and win
kolten Wong so I got my mr. kolten Wong
second baseman st. Louis Cardinals and
then two days after the draft again in
my Twitter stream I see this showman
mentioned kolten Wong is gonna have a
great season I can feel it
I just drafted him on my fantasy team
and I replied I struck like a Cobra I
jumped into Twitter and said I drafted
him to hope he has a great year right
and he said yeah and then we went back
and forth back and forth and so we
talked about kolten Wong for about six
minutes and then about three weeks later
there was a little more banter he talked
about something I jumped in reminded him
I was the kolten Wong guy we talked
about something and this time he took
notice of my profile and he said what's
vaynermedia and I said it's my agency we
do social media he think that's funny
send me a DM which for everybody here is
Twitter terms for a direct message not
public and he invited us to come and
meet with him we met with him we landed
the business and so about 13 to 16
minutes of Twitter engagement by first
doing about 13 seconds of Google
research on who the customer I wanted to
get and by not trying to sell him on my
services in the social channels which is
what 99% of b2b people do they're like
they're like 19 year old dudes they're
trying to close on the first move you
guys know what I'm talking about no I
had a little patience a little romance
little kolten Wong and I landed a four
million dollar piece of business on what
I think is happening in our world right
now which is we're living through the
rise of context if you are not sitting
in this room and not realizing there's a
word that you should really care about
and it's called context context is
what's selling we live in a world right
now my friends where content is abundant
we are producing more
tenth videos print ads television ads
songs written words we as human beings
according to Eric Schmidt the chairman
of Google are producing as much content
information to pound us with in every 48
hour window as we did from the beginning
of mankind until 2003 let me just say
that one more time from the beginning of
mankind until 2003 every word every
video every song print ad television ad
catalog direct build everything we
created is now being replicated in every
48 hour window yeah no wonder our kids
are a DD right no wonder it's so
fast-paced hey this is a good crowd for
this I have a lot of empathy for this do
you guys remember when our work days
actually ended right right remember like
back in the day when like you know I
used to think I was a workaholic I got
to the store at 8 o'clock in the morning
I left at 10 p.m. but at some level it
was kind of over at 10:00 all right I
got to get to home at 10:15 and like it
was over now if I get an email at 12:03
in the morning like people expect me to
reply at 12:04 we are living in a 24/7
365 world my friends that's why all of
you were watching television on your
time we value time now more than we
watch this I'm about to blow some of
your minds completely out of your head
watch this by show of hands and don't be
embarrassed by show of hands how many
people in this room now actually get
upset when another human being calls
them raise your hand raise it high as
one [ __ ] do me a huge favor and you
gonna get lazy I mean please stand up
I'm watching you please stand up I see
you sir don't get lazy on me yeah that's
right you in a blue please stand up if
you are upset liars and don't get lazy
amis circulations good there's a couple
more of you I will run to you because I
saw you raise your hand please stand up
if these people in this room this many
people right now are actually upset when
another human
being calls that let's clap it up for
these pioneers you can sit bruh when I
come back in three years
85% of this room will stand up to that
question what those people understand or
have started feeling is they don't
understand why you are calling them on
your time and disrespecting their time
you can text you can email as a matter
fact how many people here have started
texting or have been on the receiving
end of somebody texting them saying can
I call you right now raise your hands
that's almost everybody in this room
think about that we subconsciously
understand that we are now that that's
us being polite to the other person
we're respecting other people's - uber
how many people are familiar with uber
great so uber for the ones that aren't
is an app where you've hit one button
and a black car taxi service comes for
you starting here in San Francisco one
of the best investments I've ever made
when I invested in it people are like
who needs a black car this is you know
this is such a one-percent problem right
it was this kind of conversation what
people don't understand is boomers not
selling transportation uber selling time
in New York City everybody told me it
would have no prayer we have the best
transportation system you can get around
easily but if I can get an uber that
guarantees it's gonna be there for
minutes versus the chance that I can't
get a cab for five minutes I'm doing it
because we value time my friends the
people in this room that are selling
whether b2b or b2c you are not
respecting your customers time you're
pounding them with messages that are
selfishly good for you come and see my
thing
come to my open house check out my
development check out my thing you are
pounding them the people in this room
that understand in 2014 that we are now
living in a world where I look at all of
your faces and it's a good-looking crowd
I look at all of your faces and I say to
myself every one of these people is in
the media business first and then what
they think they're doing as you sit here
and you think about what do I do for a
living if I ask you one by one
I'm telling you you're in the media you
need to educate me about mortgages not
sell me mortgages you need to educate me
not only just about of mortgages but
everything that has to do with the home
world and then I will respect your
business even more we need to provide
value supply and demand of attention we
are living through a massive problem
with supply and demand of attention
everybody here is being fragmented what
do you think your direct mail piece and
the how many people here can't wait to
leave this conference go home open their
mailbox and carefully go through their
direct mail that's what I thought yet
plenty people here are marketing in a
way that doesn't map to their behavior
plenty of people here spending tons of
money and tons of effort trying to get
to customers how many people here want
to get cold called zero how many people
cold call plenty got it how many people
here love going to their LinkedIn and
getting spammed by 80 people that are
trying to get to them to sell nobody how
many people do it a shitload we mark it
in a way that has nothing to do to the
way that we want to be sold and that
blows my mind the bad behavior that is
going on in the business world in 2014
right this minute in a world where there
is alternatives that we could be looking
at is interesting to me meaning how many
people here by show of hands and if you
raise your hand I swear to god I'm gonna
run out to you ask you where you're
doing it and double check because I
don't want you to lie to this question I
will double check and then I will tweet
to my million followers that you were a
liar how many people in this room are
doing Facebook dark posts to sell for
their business
raise your hand zero
my friends this is the creme de la creme
of this industry there's not a person
that raised their hand to that question
as a matter of fact watch this how many
people here have no idea what the [ __ ]
of Facebook dark posts raise your hand
very good everyone I stand in front of
you right now June 2014 and I tell you
that Facebook dark posts is the best
converting to sales product that I have
seen since Google AdWords in 1999 in 15
years of marketing banner retargeting
website content production Twitter
Facebook organic for the last five years
right this minute Facebook dark posts
they are also known as Facebook
unpublished posts what they are is how
many people here have a Facebook fan
page for their business raise your hand
great so a lot of you remember for the
last five years what we've been doing
right build up your fan page right like
an email list to build up your page and
to put out stuff to them and it's better
than email because the truth is they see
it and they could share it so it has the
word of mouth that email used to have
guys do you remember back in 1997-98
when we used to get an email and we
would forward it to everybody in our
address book
remember that behavior crazy anyway how
would you like to friends be able to
reach every single person on Facebook if
you wanted to that's what a Facebook
dark posts no longer do you have to
build up a fan page you now have the
ability to go on an admin in Facebook
and create a query maybe you want to
target people that just got married
right and just changed their job in the
last week might be somebody who is
moving and looking for a new home right
or how would you like the target get
somebody who spent fifty thousand
dollars at Home Depot in the last 60
days or a million other queries that now
Facebook has on the back end that allows
you to target 17 people with these seven
different variables or 17,000 or
17 million you want to go broad you want
to target 18 the 31 year old females
that like Beyonce you're able to you
want to focus on 18 the 31 year old
women that like Beyonce live in st.
Louis like kolten Wong and drink beer
great 29 of those and you can tell them
something very specific I am running ads
that cost me a thousand dollars and
converting forty thousand dollars in
wine sales because I'm targeting
somebody so narrow I've got clients we
sold a four million dollar part for one
of our clients on a Facebook dark post
b2b because we were able to plan on the
back end the place that the person went
to college because we knew all the
people that held that job went to
Carnegie Mellon right and so my friends
please if you leave with anything from
this leave with go Google what a
Facebook dark posts s go give that
information to whoever runs your
marketing and understand that what I
talked about where all my money is being
made where all the business
opportunities are is to market in the
year that we live in right now Facebook
dark posts cost a certain amount in 24
months when everybody's doing Facebook
dark posts that same thing that you can
run for a thousand dollars is gonna cost
you fifteen thousand dollars that's just
how it works
I own the word wine on Google first
result for five cents nine months nobody
bid me up
now that's an $18 word if you do any
google SEO or SEM I know this my friends
I know more than the Sun will come up
tomorrow this one statement marketers
ruin everything it's what we do and I'm
proud of it when I saw snapchat while
you were all debating if it was sexting
I couldn't wait to figure out how to
ruin that [ __ ] ghost with my my
concepts how many people here signed up
for Groupon LivingSocial one of those
deal the day daily candy sites raise
your hand email services Groupon
LivingSocial reason one more time I want
to make sure how many people signed up
remember three years ago when you signed
up and you couldn't wait to get 42
worth the sushi for 20 bucks when that
was the best how do you like that now
you hate it because marketers ruin
everything how many people have done
email marketing in their career or a
close to the email newsletter in their
business raise your hand oh great great
number you this Wow great
wait you hear what I'm about to tell you
1997 winelibrary.com email service 1997
400,000 people on the list 89.9% open
rates just for the people that don't do
email marketing here if you're in the
30s right now you're a genius right why
marketers ruin everything
in 1997 how many people had email in
1997 raise it remember we read every
goddamn word because marketers hadn't
ruined it yet spam hadn't taken over and
you just read everything cuz you thought
there were letters that's what we did
with letters we've read everything same
thing is happening on Facebook right now
how many people have facebook on their
phone and check it once in a while raise
your hands great so as you know you're
going through baby pictures friends
pictures this and that but then
something you did you know but it seems
right because you're into it Facebook
dark posts sponsored they know who you
are you've given a lot of data you've
given data to other places like your
MasterCard behavior and all this other
stuff you may sit here and think ooh
that's spooky but the truth is nobody
gives a [ __ ] about privacy you think you
do but your behavior proves that you
don't and so there they are and you're
actually seeing them this is not a
banner ad on the right side of a website
that you don't see anymore this is right
there right there and everybody in this
room could take advantage of this tactic
and sell a hell of a lot more homes get
a lot more contract deals sell their
supplies to development projects and
people sign what more people for
mortgages whatever you want every person
here b2b b2c can use this tactic and it
will work for 18 months at a certain
press and then everybody's gonna figure
it out and to be more expensive and it
will still work and you'll still do it
but for the next 18 months you can get
more upside yet not a soul in here knows
what it is and not one person does it
and by the way with all respect you'll
feel good about this this is a
consistent theme for the last 60 days of
every conference on that even the most
progressive marketers because the truth
is we talked about headlines
in this room read a Wall Street Journal
headline that said Facebook organic
reaches down and have debated is
Facebook worth it right you might have
read the Gallup poll that surveyed
14,000 people this week that said social
media doesn't sell anything that's fun
they went to people 14,000 of them said
hey John do you think social media makes
you buy stuff guys none of us who want
to think we're being manipulated by
marketing if I asked you if you think
commercials sell you something you would
say no or Direct Mail no or email no or
social no and so we live in a world look
we live in a world of headline reading
that's what I do
I've stopped talking about everything I
realized as I listened to all the
smartest marketers talked about Facebook
and Twitter and all this stuff and
realize how dumb they are in it because
they're not practitioners their headline
readers I said man that's how I must
sound when I talk about health care or
politics so actually I don't talk about
[ __ ] anymore
I just talked about the Jets wine and
social media you come up to me later I
want to talk about something else I'm
not talking to you I'm scared to sound
that dumb and so I'm talking about the
details the practitioner I'm talking
about the fact that if you search open
house on Twitter twitter.com slash
search that if you went there right now
and you typed in open house and you saw
the hundreds of people that every
Thursday and Friday say I'm going to
open houses this weekend and you realize
that if you're trying to sell homes in
the real estate business or as a
development that you could just jump in
and say hey I hope you have a good time
not come to my development or come to my
land some no have a good time just like
I said hey kolten Wong they're gonna see
who you are in the profile they'll get
there don't try to close on that first
move twitter is the town square
the cocktail-hour of our generation it's
free and everybody keeps disrespecting
it because here's my favorite there are
people in this room that have drawn
lines in the sand right people this room
who've been successful for a long time
people this room who've seen talks like
I'm giving right now ten years ago
saying the Internet's coming and you're
gonna go out of business right you've
heard this hyperbole before here's what
scares me
the Internet is maturing we're at year
20 now and what's happening is
innovation is happening quicker Airbnb
goes from idea to really bothering the
hotel industry in 36 months
uber goes from idea to completely
disrupting the taxi black car industry
in 36 months the innovation we're living
through my friends is faster and that's
what we have to pay attention to we are
living through the biggest culture shift
of our time the Internet is the Second
Industrial Revolution it will touch
every single industry and if you
underestimate it it will Bowl you over
one by one one by one one by one and so
I implore you to pay attention to how to
talk because we're under estimating
what's really happening which is we're
living through the disruption of
communication how many people here have
a 16 to 22 year old child or grandchild
raise your hand great remember three
years ago when you had this conversation
hey little Ricky hey Susan I don't give
a crap how you talk to your friends but
when your father and mother call you
pick up the damn phone remember that
just curious how'd that work out for you
uh-huh and for the people in here that
don't have a child in that range the
reason they're laughing is this there
are a grown-ass men in this room who in
the last 24 hours have texted lol and
OMG and we're under estimating what that
means because when 55 year old John and
62 year old Carl get forced to text
because a fourteen-year-old Susan and 13
year old Cindy then they start talking
to each other on text we are living
through the youth of vacation of our
society my friends the biggest trend
that everybody has to figure out here
because you may say oh well the 20 year
olds are not buying the kind of homes
I'm selling right well you're under
estimating is the youth of vacation if
you're lucky enough I want you to sit
here and think for a second if you're
lucky in a fortune enough to have known
your parent at the age that you are
right now if you're lucky enough to be
sitting here and know how old you are
and knew your parent at that age just
think for one second right now how much
older they were at your age right now
than you I mean it's remarkable if you
look at the data right now the average
46 year old woman in her behavior what
she wears what she spends her money on
what she does for entertainment how she
rolls
the average 46 year old woman right now
acts more like a 29 year old woman just
ten years ago as a matter of fact you
guys familiar with selfies who knows it
selfies are got it here's a good one the
fastest-growing sector of people telling
taking selfies are forty to forty eight
year old women that's right friends
cougar selfies
you agree with me but what's gonna
happen next Thursday when you'd hit your
number or there's a bad meeting or
something happened we need this room
this industry with zero hands on
Facebook dark posts I don't even want to
get into Pinterest don't even get me
started on Pinterest Pinterest will be
the single most important platform for
this industry in 36 months write it down
Pinterest will be the most important
platform digitally for everybody in this
room because Pinterest is intent to buy
people go on there and they search
pictures they're not there to keep up
with their friends or their friends kids
like they are on Facebook they are there
to window-shop 3.0 right and it leads to
sales the amount of developers and look
my minority investor in my agency that I
took money from very recently this guy
by name of Steve Ross
he owns related real estate and some of
the stuff we've been able to do he's
building an 18 billion-dollar project
right now on the West Side Highway
called Hudson Yards right and when I
look at what they want to do to promote
it which is let's buy full-page ads in
New York Times right and all that stuff
it just blows my mind and when we show
them just the little things that a
Pinterest or a Facebook can do for a
hundredth of the price and that's what
I'm talking about my friends Instagram
another platform but you can't track the
sales
it's like print there's no linking out
of Instagram however every 15 to 35
year-old in America right now is
spending an ungodly amount of time in
their Instagram account it is the new
Facebook and so there are plenty of
things going on and we can continue to
ignore them you're more than welcome
you're gonna roll and run your business
the way you want to but I implore you if
you get anything out of this talk if you
got up this early if you skip the USA
Germany game if you went to sleep at
2:00 a.m. because you drank a crapload
last night and you still got here at
8:30 if you're here then I'm hoping to
bring you some level of value and that
value is simple if you want it
everything you spend your time and money
on everything organizationally
externally if you audit it list
everything you do everything
you do everyday time and everything you
spend money on and you drop the bottom
25% of the dumb [ __ ] you're doing
because you've always done it
it's your normal behavior it's what used
to bring you value and you cut that out
and you apply that 25% and to trying the
new things that are happening your
business will be dramatically healthier
because when we draw lines in the sand
we lose my friends the quickest way to
go out of business is to be romantic
about how you make your money there are
people in this room who are romantic
when somebody comes to them in their
organization you may be that person
coming to the boss in your organization
and they say hey how about this and they
look you in the face and say no no this
is how we've always done it that guy
that girl is a loser I'm not joking
that is a losing player in business and
I'm not trying to soften it that is a
losing mentality I'm trying to put
myself out of business every day I don't
give a [ __ ] about social media
I can't wait for oculus rift virtual
reality and robots and smartwatches I'm
ready
because the truth is innovation doesn't
care about you or me I'm pumped that I
understand marketing at 2014 but guess
what I can be out of business in
marketing in 2016 if I'm not willing to
put in the work and live in the world
that we actually live in and I'll close
you with this and then I want to do ten
minutes of QA so please get your
questions ready I sent a room with a CEO
of a billion-dollar company selling to
14 to 17 year old girls I came in I said
look when you spend a lot more money
this year on Instagram snapchat vine we
have to gave them all the compelling
reasons because at the end of the day
you need the attention of who you're
trying to sell to they're spending their
time in there I gave him all the data
made it all MBA Harvard Business School
for him because that's how he likes it
did all that [ __ ] and then he looked me
in the face and he said Gary this is
great stuff he goes I gotta be honest
with you I just don't get Instagram and
I look him in the face and I said that's
great dick
oh no that's his name this is it sorry I
go that's great dick I go but you're not
a 13 year old girl and so you sit here
and you say to yourself as the developer
as the proprietor that's the guy
well I'm not on Instagram but I don't
check Facebook it doesn't matter what
you do it matters what your customer
does and if you underestimate the
innovation of what's happening at the
customer level in 2014 and if you don't
understand that 10 years ago Facebook
Twitter YouTube smartphones did not
exist 10 years ago and you apply what's
gonna happen in 10 years and you don't
understand you be looking for a job
thank you thank you thanks mother
thank you